[Music]
has been a memorable week for the new
judging panel on American Idol but to
change the 40 25 million dollars a day
caused huge drama between the network
and her fellow judges just flapping back
knees so silly only 24 hours in is Katie
laughing all the way to the bank
[Music]
a new report says her rumor 25 million
dollar payday blued the budget igniting
fireworks between Luke Bryan and Lila
Ritchie who were left demanding more
money more than like pretty much any guy
that's been on that show
ABC reportedly wanted to spend no more
than fifty million on talents so if
Katie got twenty five and host Ryan
Seacrest got fifteen that would have
left five million each for Luke and
Lionel but what were they initially
offered reportedly half that hello that
could explain why it took 136 days of
negotiations to fill the judge's table
the guy salary now reportedly still less
than a third of Katie's at 7 million H
boom we revert back to how people
handled us in our past to get here Luke
and Katie just met for the first time
wrapping two days of ten hour-long
auditions the show premieres at 2018 ABC
refutes these figures and denies any
negotiation drama but does telling T
quote the deals were done within the
original budget meantime Jamie's ex
Russell Brand is happy she got her cash
I certainly wouldn't comment on how much
he's earning in the negative I wish her
all the best all right so there may not
be any love lost there but paychecks
aside there's a lot of love I think
chemistry with the new Idol judges
[Music]
you